like i'm gonna give you the truth yeah
nightmares happened midnight mass is
done there's something else to come
good morning i know i'm not who you
expected to see just know i'm only here
to help and i look forward to meeting
you all hi guys good to see you today
as always kate we will be talking
spoilers zach don't worry i've promised
netflix that they can have an angel come
and take my cat away if anything gets
out so we're gonna be good
that cat's in trouble yeah no one can
save the cats
[Music]
kate once again your brilliant husband
mike flanagan gave us a series that will
give us nightmares all month when you
and i chatted last year for blind manor
you definitely said we were getting
something different and this is
certainly not the haunting of crockett
island midnight mass is its own thing
how did this series come about it's been
in various forms it was a the beginning
of a novel it was a movie for a minute
and then it was a series that was taken
around town and everybody passed on it
and so and now it's got a second's
chance it's sort of one of those plants
that's like the corpse flower that only
blooms once a year and we just happen to
hit it at its perfect bloom i think a
slow grower i know you struggled
with what happened that's what i did
yes
zach at what point in the process did
mike let you know that you would be
killed by a vampire like angel and then
brought back to life and then burned
into dust in a boat in the middle of the
sea like and what was your reaction to
that so he never really let me know once
i got the job i just got a bunch of
scripts emailed to me
and um so i just read it i did know at
some point i was gonna die i didn't know
how i actually was uh informed first by
hamish who was able to read the scripts
before me and he sent me these texts
he's like oh my god you just died
[Laughter]
i was like oh what episode he was like
four i was like oh okay i didn't i knew
i was gonna die i didn't know when he's
like wait i'm reading five
you're alive again
i was like oh cool that goes oh my god
you died again
i was like okay so i guess at the end of
five i die but i didn't know how until i
read it and i just got to watch that
episode the other night and i remember
reading it i and i said to mike and this
is so long ago i was like the way that
episode ends with her just screaming in
a boat is on the page amazing like it
always like it resonated with me it
horrified me i don't wanna say profound
but i'll say profound and then when i
got to watch it to hear uk continue to
scream over the credits it was
horrifying
well it's a brilliant choice because one
of the things mike and i talked about in
that moment is how long it takes for the
human body to burn to ash it's not a
short thing and it's grotesque and she's
in the boat the whole time and obviously
you don't want to leave the camera on me
because like there's only so many times
i can scream like that
and i'm trying to get like
get the air underneath me and so it
gives a sense of that time and then it
puts aaron in because the next episode
starts
let's say 15 minutes after that moment
so you you know that aaron was in this
void of trauma for x amount of time and
i think his choice to run the scream
over the credits brings the audience in
that a little bit
you have the best scream on tv kate
honestly it was so good did mike give
you ice cream after that episode like
what was your like i'm so sorry that i
had you do that for so long present
first of all i'm lactose intolerant so i
feel attacked second of all
i think mike barely
yeah mike gave me a good job and then i
went back to my room
no i think it's very much at a certain
point with this troupe of actors
everybody knows what everybody's
strength is it's like a great sports
team ready for a sports analogy exactly
so it's like no i'm ready okay it's like
a volleyball team and so we know who the
spikers are so we can set and spike and
so for example if you need a death stare
you're going to set up sloyan because
that like stillness and stare
zach's like you did not go with the
football analogy at all it's supposed to
be fun i love i love volleyball what i'm
shaking my head at
you sat and spiked
[Music]
you used your tiny t-rex arms and then
france
when you did you sat and spiked so i
think mike was just just glad that his
pinch hitter made a bass hit what is it
that words are you're not his pinch hit
now you're just off the rail you're
clearly not his pin [ __ ] or he's hired
you multiple times
you're his muse you're his designer
he brings you in to hit the grand slam
at the end of the game when you're the
only person you can rely on that's a
good sports metaphor i can't feel my
legs as soon as the fans finish this
they're gonna say is there going to be
another midnight mass no
sorry
i remember because i told you when we
were talking blind like i'll like i'm
going to give you the truth yeah
nightmares happened midnight mass is
done there's something else to come
there's the midnight club which zach is
going to be in
did someone say mark what uh
nothing it's bad inside what can you
tell us about the midnight club and does
it have any
thing to do
no midnight
yeah it's a lot of midnight um it's a
lot of nights but no midnight club is a
totally different thing like totally
different it's a really cool fun show
it's
super depressing uh it's about uh young
18 to 22 year olds who go to a hospice
to die um and tell each other stories
before they do there's like a haunting
aspect like a why a show it's a why
horror show where you have the it's
almost like if we all grew up with are
you afraid of the dark where it's a
group of people who get together in the
middle of night and tell each other
stories so you have the story of those
people and every episode you get a
second small genre story coming to
netflix in spooky season 2022. yeah yeah
i am so glad that you will be with us
for what comes next okay you know how
much i love haunting would we ever get
another chapter honestly i can't answer
that for you because i'm going to
disappoint you so i'm going to say
nothing at all wait but i got to ask you
like as a fan like i was a huge fan of
it didn't everyone die like what's the
next chapter their anthology
right so they want oh oh
this hunting at that i know you will get
what i can tell you is you will have
that experience again you will meet a
new group of people and terrible things
will happen to them and you will love
them and mike will kill everybody you
love i promise you that and then you can
have another baby that's named after
your character and i love this i would
love to just have a a bunch of babies
that's basically my imdb page
you